it's leela is that did i say that right
yeah all right leela in logan utah i did
it
yes all right so what's going on how's
it going in your world
um you know there's a lot up in the air
but we're excited about the future and
i'm really excited to talk to you
about it i'm excited to talk to you so
what's going on
okay so i have two kids i have a two and
a half year old
and i have a six month old oh you are in
it right
yeah just wait so much in it
oh girl about four months ago my two and
a half year old
who had been weaned for a full year
decided that she needed to breastfeed
again like her little brother
oh she's back all right yeah so we've
been doing that for four months at first
i thought she was curious so i was like
we'll go with it she'll get over this
really fast
she weaned so easily she was all into
like real food
this isn't going to be a thing so now
it's like she's asking for milk more
than he does
and i am dehydrated and just like kind
of emotionally exhausted
yes like i cuddle with her and i want to
spend time with her
but i also i don't want it to always be
involving milk and i don't know how to
like transition
and keep him being breastfeed yes so
tandem breastfeeding right i i've heard
about this i've
read about this you're the first person
i'm actually experi like talking through
this with
and so your two and a half year old i
guess at the time she was a little over
two
she came back and was it something you
were excited to do did you feel guilty
about it was it just a weird
so okay i don't think breastfeeding
itself is weird at all
so i've been like good with that i love
the cuddles with my kids
so that wasn't an issue but then she was
just so curious and i try not to say
no to her unless i have a really good
reason to say now i let her be curious
about stuff
right so i was like okay we'll see where
this goes and i just thought
this was going to be like a one-time
thing and then she's going to be over it
no way
dude yeah no way man
she gets that direct line connection she
gets to be between you
and this other new lunatic that you
brought into the home right
she gets to weasel right between those
two weasel's not a nice way to say that
but
um so let's take the the two kids off
for a second
you mentioned the physical part of this
but you also
you said it i don't like to say no um so
you're in the middle
of emotional spiritual psychological
world i don't mean spiritual like in the
the whatever the jesus he churchy sense
i mean spiritual like
this is existential for you so there is
a part of you tell me if i'm wrong
that when you are nursing both of your
kids at once that's magical and then
there's a part of you that
this is literally wearing you out from
the inside out is that fair
both of those are 100 true okay so what
do you want to do
um or both probably right
yeah so i think like the deepest part of
me just wants my daughter to know how
much
i love her right and since this is the
way
she wants to hear it i don't know how to
change
to something else because if i say no
she just
she just is a wreck and she just cries
and she's so sad
and she doesn't get like that about
everything else and she comes
she wants milk when she's gone through
something that's scary
or hurts her right or she's just having
a hard day
and i just like i want to protect her
and she's not
cuddly so if i try to cuddle her she
like
wiggles out and she leaves
so so i'm getting something out of this
relationship that is important for me
too
but i'm waking up every morning feeling
like
like i'm getting headaches and i have
chronic pain that's worsened by
being dehydrated and i feel like no
matter how much water i drink that's not
enough
right so and so i kind of need to find
another option
i want to preface this with the last
thing on a planet earth
the world needs is a
40 year old male talking to a woman
about telling her what she needs to be
doing with breastfeeding right
the last thing the world needs is
another dude sticking his head into some
of these conversations all right
so i want to go ahead and tell everyone
there is
few things on earth with more opinions
than breastfeeding right
um there are all kinds of tribes around
all different kinds of things i get that
if you are into tandem breastfeeding for
you and for your kids
and i know what the world health
organization says about two years i know
all that stuff okay
so i'm talking to just lovely leela in
utah
and so don't send me mean cards and
letters everyone in
the podcast world so um
if that's something you want to continue
that's something you want to continue
that's between you
and your kids um i think you
know ex know exactly where the challenge
is here it
is not with your two-year-old it's with
you
um and it's that initial panic
meltdown your daughter's is it daughter
is that right
yeah okay your daughter is feeling like
she no longer owns you and this is a
great way to control you
and she is just leaning up against these
boundaries and one of the greatest
things you could teach her
is that mommy has body boundaries
and that everyone from dad to her to new
baby respects mommy's body boundaries
and anytime somebody puts up new
boundaries particularly for young kids
but even when wives put them up for
their husbands and husbands put them up
for their why
boundaries are hard for us especially at
first and
your two-year-old daughter
two-and-a-half-year-old is gonna crash
up against those boundaries and try to
kick them over
um because she just wants to see if
they're gonna hold and if they're firm
at the end of the day the bigger
challenge is not with her but it's with
you
and so i want you to feel 1 000 affirmed
that you are more than welcome to the
autonomy of your body
and you are more than welcome you're not
going to ruin your kid in fact you're
going to empower your kid
because right now she's not having to do
the work to learn the psychological
and emotional and spiritual responses to
discontent to fear to frustration she's
just literally
able to run to mom right right to mom's
bosom literally
and so what what's going to be
critical for you in this is exhausting
season and i get that
man you have a two and a half year old
and six month old there's no way around
it um
is finding intentional time not cuddle
time
but eye contact time reading time um
special mommy and daughter time with
your two and a half year old
another thing that can be key is giving
your two and a half year old jobs
participation leadership roles
especially a young
young daughter who's becoming a young
woman you're training you're raising a
young woman
and so here are some roles some
leadership opportunities she can take
but the reality is it's just going to be
hard for a little while
a great professor of mine her name was
aretha marbley she's one of the most
important mentors i've ever had
she said one of the keys to helping that
first kid when you have a second kid
is to start refer to referring to it not
as
the baby but as your sister
as your brother and two-year-olds
three-year-olds four-year-olds they
crave ownership
so much that your daughter craves
ownership of you right now
and so what you're going to be able to
do is transition that ownership from
your body
to your your sister needs your help
right now
your sister needs you to fill in the
blank here's some jobs
here are some things i need she needs
you to color a picture and read her the
story or whatever the things are
it's going to give her some autonomy but
it's just going to be a hard
frustrating tearful for you and for her
separation over the next few weeks
is dad a good participant here is he a
good helper
dad's a great helper um dad is probably
on the same page you're on he's like
she's gonna cry it's gonna be hard like
we just have to make her do it
and i just breaks my heart it does but
that's also been really busy lately he's
finishing school he's working full-time
we're about to move so jolly so
so the real thing that you've got to do
leela the real thing you've got to do is
recognize the truth that you are also
using this
as a stress coping mechanism too
and if you can come up in this messy
crazy season and i realize i'm on such
thin
ice being just a dude telling a nursing
mom
you know what you need to do i get that
right but
um your husband's busy you got a six
month old who's not sleeping through the
night you've got a two and a half year
old you're about to move transition
transition transition
it does make everybody just exhale a
little bit when you've got both kids
that are quiet
both of your babies your gut you've got
huddled up on your you know
i can't even imagine the connection you
can have with a child there
i hugged my daughter this morning we
just she just woke up a little bit early
and we just got some great snuggle time
this morning
i can't imagine how much deeper that
could be right than what you get to
experience
but you've got to start developing and
owning and getting some
friends in your life that can push you
and hold you accountable to getting some
stress coping skills that don't
involve your two and a half year old
that don't involve your six month old
you've got to start coming up with some
things for you in whatever limited
squishy time you've got that will bring
you peace and it will bring you some
restoration
is that fair i know that's so hard yeah
it's just a totally different way than
how i've been thinking about it but it's
very valid and that helps to see it that
way
or maybe oh gosh i'm just thinking about
the the
the breastfeeding cards and letters i'm
gonna get um
maybe don't send them mean letters may
be thinking about me thinking about
your daughter as she's not a xanax
and so every time she comes to you and
you're just
thinking she's not my pacifier she's not
my xanax
and this is gonna be hard for a few
weeks but and making sure you know what
your steps are gonna be
i'm gonna this is i'm gonna go take a
walk this is gonna get some sleep this
is i'm gonna go talk to somebody because
i'm struggling
whatever those things are um but i i
think your heart is so there
and your husband's right you got an
awesome partner you're i'm smiling right
now because i know this is going to be
hard but it's going to be so worth it
and i'll tell you this if you can teach
your daughter
how to appropriately respond if you can
model for her body boundaries if you can
model for her
when mommy gets tired and stressed
here's the healthy things i do
you are setting her up for a
extraordinary
legacy shifting life and if you teach
her
that when things get bad mommy will just
hold you and i'll always take care of
the discomfort and whenever you get
scared and fearful mommy will solve
those problems for you
that's a hard road to owe now she's two
right of course mom's gonna be there
right um and i'm not telling you well it
sucks kid go outside and go for a jog
right no she's two and a half right
um but beginning to hold those
boundaries hold that autonomy you get
your wellness behavior you put your
oxygen mask on first
and give her some ownership and autonomy
and now she is
a she's a big sister and she's going to
learn some new skills and new boundaries
there it's going to be extraordinary so
thank you so much for that call leela
you are awesome your husband's awesome
your kids
it's gonna be a blast um and i will be
thinking about you during the next few
weeks as you all transition
to where you're just breastfeeding one
kid which already sounds
like a cartwheel box of monkeys and
adventures